i think this human comparison also lends
itself to some rhetoric that's pretty
misleading
so over the past five decades you've
probably seen some headlines that look
like this
no jobs blame the robots
well that headline would be a little
more accurate if it was no jobs blame
company decisions driven by unbridled
corporate capitalism
not such a pithy headline but more
accurate because it's not the robots
taking the jobs right thinking of robots
as quasi-humans giving them this agency
in our language really lends itself to a
determinism about our future and about
the automation of labor when in reality
we have choices we don't like to see
this but we have choices we could be
using technology to help people do a
better job rather than trying to
automate them away
if you look at warehouse workers today
it's kind of like that charlie chaplin
movie modern times where companies have
automated as much of the process as they
can and so they're treating the human
workers like a part of the machine
they have scan guns that count down the
seconds between tasks they make them do
things that they are clearly hoping that
they can eventually automate once the
technology gets better but that's not
the only way to think about or handle
human labor like a replaceable commodity
so take for example the united states
patent and trademark office i know that
a lot of patent and trademark offices
are dealing with the problem that
you have patent examiners that get tons
of applications on their desk they need
to decide whether any invention is new
enough to warrant patent protection and
so technically they have to sift through
all of the world's information in order
to make that determination which is
impossible
and
so you know one of the things that the
united states patented trademark office
could have done which i have seen
companies do is they could have said
i wonder if we could train artificial
intelligence
on you know the historic data that we
have and have it make determinations
that are you know have a slightly better
hit rate than the examiners because even
if it's just slightly better than the
very poor job that we're doing right now
then we can get rid of all these people
and not have to pay them their salaries
no instead what they said was how can we
use this technology to help our people
do a better job and so they started
looking for ways to use ai to surface
some of the prior art that the examiners
wouldn't have found on their own
and then letting the humans do what they
do best which is make that judgment call
that determination
[Music]